joining us now the man who was the first
overall pick in the 2021 draft the first
time the jaguars ever had the first
overall pick in their history and it
goes to quarterback trevor lawrence
trevor how are you pal
i'm doing great mike thank you guys for
having me i appreciate it i appreciate
some of your time i know it's a crazy
time for you with otas and everything
else happening and the first thing i
have to say and it's probably the most
important topic that i can get into
your dog is awesome and i say that
because your dog looks exactly like our
dog what is your dog's name
her name's indy you guys have a
bernadoodle yes
i'm telling you
they look exactly like i left the door
open just in case she wanders down here
but that was the first thing we're
watching the draft draft night and they
cut to the the video
after you got picked and then comes the
dog and my son says that looks just like
macy so
awesome dog though right yeah she's a
great guy she just got a bad haircut so
i'm hoping she doesn't walk in here
she's looked better she's had she's seen
better days for sure
that's the thing though every once in a
while groomer catches a wild hair and
macy comes home and it's like where's
our dog what's this what's his thing
yeah but then like two weeks later she
looks like she always did yeah
so uh
how many people have said to you in
jacksonville you need a haircut
uh not too many you know
i haven't seen that many people i've
been uh at the facility every day just
just trying to get ready man but uh
yeah it's uh it's always it's always fun
going to a new place and just kind of
feeling your way around so that's what
we're doing right now hey and i have
some fun with you on that because my
hair wasn't quite as long as yours when
i was your age but i know my mom was
always on me to get it cut to the point
where when i'd visit the threat was once
you're asleep i'm coming in with the
scissors you don't get any heat from
family members to get the haircut yeah
so i mean actually my my dad and my mom
a little bit but more so my dad were
always
trying to get me to cut it and then i
think he just eventually got to a point
where he just gave up because he doesn't
he doesn't think in a few years about it
well just be careful sleep with one eye
open whenever you're visiting or
whenever they're visiting you you never
know if there's scissors or shears
around they'll get the dog first
and then they'll come get you after that
um you talked about your pitch count
during rookie mini camp 30 to 40 throws
per day after your warm up where does it
stand right now
we've increased it um i'm trying to
think of the exact numbers we're
probably around
we're probably around 60 a day right now
and we typically practice you know three
four days a week so
do the math i don't know i can't do that
quick in my head however many per week
so we went up a little bit we've
progressed and i'm feeling really good
getting back in good shape throwing wise
and we're making good progress you know
there's not many things that i can't do
there's a few things that we're just not
doing right now just to be cautious but
you know i'd imagine in the next couple
weeks i'll be let loose pretty much
are you conscious of it at all just from
the standpoint of you want to protect it
you just want to be careful with it or
you feel like you're able to do what you
need to do
yeah honestly i don't have to think
about it too much like there's some
things on you know exchanges some
handoffs and stuff that i'm being a
little bit careful about not to you know
hit it or stretch it too much but
really it feels great i i think i i can
do anything i needed to do if need be
but there's no point in rushing it you
know i've gotten this far along i don't
want to do something dumb to have a
setback now so we're just being careful
but i feel great when i'm out there i'm
not thinking about it at all hey trevor
give me one thing about your experience
so far i know it's not even been a month
yet but give me one thing about what
you've experienced so far that you
didn't expect
um
huh
i just honestly everything's been so new
i don't even know what i expected coming
in i was just coming in like
ready to
adjust to whatever so
i think it's just different you know
it's going to be different than college
but actually experiencing that
is hard to get ready for and just the
way
people prepare how they take care of
their bodies like everyone's pros now in
college it's like you got guys that
are there and we we had great players
and great teammates and people that
really did above and beyond what they
were asked but still you got guys that
hey when do i need to be here and
they're there then right when it's done
they're out they're going home and you
got guys here that are there early
trying to get ready getting their bodies
warmed up or studying and then you got
guys staying late getting treatment for
hours after practice and just seeing the
commitment of everyone has been cool and
for me learning how to be a pro and
learning my daily routine of what i need
to be my best and whether that's extra
studying at night if that's getting
there a little bit early to warm up if
that's staying an extra hour for some
treatment
all those things and just real like you
know learning what i need i'm still
learning that but i'm on a pretty good
schedule now so that's been something
that i've had to adjust to for sure
coach meyer stopped short before the
draft of saying that you would be the
first pick although he came very close a
couple of times and i know they want to
have an element of surprise publicly on
the night of the draft when did you know
that you were going to be the guy
yeah i'm i'm the kind of guy that never
really wants to put the cart before the
horse so i didn't make any assumptions
but i you know i probably knew
trying to think i don't know probably
sometime in in march
i was thinking like this is probably
going this direction but
now you know you never want to say for
sure that something's going to happen so
i was keeping all my options open and
just trying to stay ready for whatever
but i knew that was
likely gonna be
the spot where i land so
i kind of put kind of figured there they
put up the video of their
effort to call you
when they were on the clock three times
three times what happened with that
yeah i don't know honestly i really i
was sitting there by my phone had my had
my bose headphones in there just waiting
and
honestly
so i live in kind of in the woods in
south carolina that was where my place
was and it was like the service is
terrible so
that as i guess that's what it was but i
never got the calls people people are
texting me like i didn't know you hung
up on them three times in a row i'm like
i didn't even get the calls oh and the
biggest news in all that you haven't set
up your voicemail what the hell
i i know i can't set up a voicemail i
can't let people know they got the right
number if they're trying
um
when did you find out that tim tebow was
gonna be your teammate did coach tell
you before they they signed him
no we uh
i actually
funny we were sitting there in the
facility eating lunch um
up above like kind of in the stadium and
it pops up on the big jumbotron hey
breaking news tim tebow signing with
jacksonville so we we knew that this was
a possibility just from what we've seen
but we weren't sure
and that was the first time i met him
was last week and we've had three
practices together now he's been great
what's been your impression of him as a
tight end because this is as brand new
for him as it is for you in the nfl as a
quarterback
yeah i mean he's in what i can say is
he's in great shape you can tell he's
been working getting ready for for an
opportunity if he gets one and um like i
said you can tell he's ready he's really
smart i think that it helps that he
played quarterback for a number of years
and learned a few different systems so
now learning a new system at tight end
is probably
a little bit less as far as the learning
curve just because he's just learning
the tight end position now so
um he's great from that standpoint i
think just what he brings to the team
that's just a guy you want to be around
great character
uh super hard worker just does things
the right way
and those are the first you know initial
impressions for me
and trevor i know you're with us today
on behalf of gatorade and we thank them
for making you available tell us what
you have going on with gatorade
yeah so i was fortunate enough to be
able to present the 2021 gatorade
national football player of the year
award to jackson dart out of utah
and it was cool you know i was able to
uh receive the award the state player of
the year award when i was in high school
and then on the flip side being able to
present the national football player of
the year award to jackson was really
cool to be a part of
obviously it's you know it's the biggest
high school sports award and just to be
associated with that for me and for
jackson is really cool
and then i really love what they stand
for you know it's not just about the
performance on the field it's you know
it's how well you're doing in school
it's how you're impacting your community
and i think that's
really something that people can aspire
to do and to be is someone that just
helps people so i'm i'm honored to be a
part of it oh it's great stuff and we
appreciate you being part of it we
appreciate gatorade last one on the way
out do you have your passport because
you're going to need it
i do i do i got it uh i got it in
college actually so
prepared ready ready to be the jaguars
quarterback before you even finished
your time at clemson great stuff trevor
it's great talking to you it's great to
finally meet you we wish you all the
best as your rookie season approach and
we hope to talk to you very soon yeah
man i appreciate it mike thank you guys
for having me
all right trevor thank you man
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports